BUT FIRST, DEMOCRATS CANCEL
AMERICA.
THAT’S TONIGHT’S ANGLE.
FOR THE PAST 40 PLUS YEARS
LIBERALS SUCCESSFULLY PURGED
ALMOST ALL CONSERVATIVES FROM
ACADEMIA, THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY AND JOURNALISM.
ONE BY ONE THOSE SECTORS
ULTIMATELY FELL VICTIM TO
OPPRESSIVE GROUPTHINK WHICH HAD
A TERRIBLE EFFECT ON THEIR WORK
PRODUCT AND CREDIBILITY.
DISSENT WAS NOT TOLERATED AND
THE PUNISHMENT FOR DEVIATING
FROM THE SENTIMENT DU JOUR GREW
HARSHER OVER TIME.
EVEN LIBERALS AREN’T IMMUNE.
WHO CAN FORGET WHEN THE COMEDIAN
KEVIN HART LOST HIS OSCARS GIG A
FEW YEARS BACK OR HOW COLLEGES
HAVE ROUTINELY REACTED TO
CONSERVATIVE SPEAKERS ON CAMPUS?
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> Laura: OR HOW COLUMNISTS,
EVEN THOSE WHO ARE
PRO-GAY MARRIAGE, THEY LOSE
THEIR POSITIONS WHEN THEY SEE
SOMETHING SHOCKINGLY SCIENCE
BASED.
MEANWHILE SHUT OUT FROM JOBS
AFFECTING THE CULTURE, AND
TRADITIONALISTS ARE FAIR-MINDED
PEOPLE WHO WENT INTO LAW AND MAY
BE A BUSINESS AND DURING
REPUBLICAN ADMINISTRATIONS, SOME
OF THEM WORK IN GOVERNMENT.
I’M FISCALLY CONSERVATIVE BUT A
SOCIAL LIBERAL BEGIN THE
ACCEPTABLE WAY FOR MAINSTREAM
TYPES TO DESCRIBE THEIR CULTURAL
BELIEFS.
AS WE HAVE BEEN REMINDED OVER
THE LAST 14 DAYS OR SO THE
CULTURE IS WHERE THE BATTLE WILL
BE WON OR LOST.
THERE ARE TIMES THAT SPELL
AMERICA WITH THE KKK, YELLING IN
THE FACES OF POLICE OFFICERS OR
NATIONAL GUARDSMEN.
REMEMBER THEY LEARN THIS
BEHAVIOR FROM EITHER THEIR
RADICAL PARENTS FOR THEIR
PROGRESSIVE TEACHERS, OR MAYBE
ACTIVIST CELEBRITIES.
ALL VALIDATED ALONG THE WAY BY A
FAWNING PRESS COURT.
WHAT WE ARE WITNESSING IS A
RELENTLESS PROPAGANDA WAR
AGAINST THE OLD TEACHINGS ABOUT
AMERICA.
IT’S AN EFFORT TO SMEAR OUR
HISTORY AND OUR PATRIOTIC
SPIRIT.
FOR DECADES, CONSERVATIVES FROM
VILLA/LASHLEY WARNED ABOUT THE
POISONOUS EFFECTS OF THE
CULTURAL MONOPOLY, BUT THEY WERE
LARGELY IGNORED.
AFTER THE DEATH OF TRUE LIBERALS
LIKE CHRISTOPHER HITCHENS, I’M
HARD-PRESSED TO NAME ANY
PROMINENT LIBERAL WHO WOULD
OPENLY OPPOSE TODAY’S CANCEL
CULTURE.
THIS WAS HITCHENS IN 2006.
>> IT’S NOT JUST THE RISE OF THE
PERSON WHO SPEAKS TO BE HEARD
IT, IT IS THE RISE OF EVERYONE
IN THE AUDIENCE TO LISTEN AND TO
HEAR.
EVERY TIME YOU SILENCED
SOMEBODY, YOU MAKE YOURSELF
PRISONER OF YOUR INACTION
BECAUSE YOU DENY YOURSELF THE
RIGHT TO HEAR SOMETHING.
>> Laura: WE MISS HIM.
A FEW DECADES BACK, MANY
REPUBLICANS AND EVEN SOME
LIBERALS DISMISSED THINGS LIKE
CRITICAL FEMINIST THEORY AND
CRITICAL RACE THEORY AT OUR
UNIVERSITY IS THAT WERE KIND OF
HARMLESS MUSINGS OF A RADICAL
FRENCH.
TODAY THOSE THEORIES ARE
MAINSTREAM BECAUSE GOOD
ACADEMICS AND ADMINISTRATORS
WERE JUST TOO WEAK OR TOO AFRAID
TO PUSH BACK.
SO NOW YOU CAN’T READ UP
HUCKLEBERRY FINN WITHOUT HEARING
THAT, MACBETH, WITHOUT BEING
LECTURED ABOUT SHAKESPEARE’S
MISOGYNY.
AND, THAT’S WHAT I’M CALLING
THEM.
THESE ARE -- THEY ARE EAGER TO
WIPE AWAY EVERYTHING THAT CAME
BEFORE THEM.
THEY WANT TO FORCE EVERYONE ELSE
TO BEG FOR FORGIVENESS.
NOW WHY WOULD ANYONE BE
SURPRISED THAT A STATUE OF
CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS WAS PULLED
DOWN AND SET ABLAZE IN RICHMOND
WITH ANOTHER IN ST. PAUL BEING
VANDALIZED TONIGHT, OR THAT
ENTIRE CITY BLOCK IN SEATTLE NOW
LOOKED LIKE MOGADISHU CIRCA
LAKE, 191 OR 192?
EVEN CORPORATE CEOs ARE
POSITIVELY PANICKED BY WHAT’S
BEEN HAPPENING IN THE STREETS
AND IF THEY ARE DESPERATE,
FALLING ALL OVER THEMSELVES TO
PLACATE OR EVEN WORK WITH THESE
NEW REVOLUTIONARIES.
G.O.P. LAWMAKERS VIOLATE THEIR
OWN PRINCIPLE OF FEDERALISM BUT
CONSIDERING PLANS TO CREATE A
NATIONAL DATABASE TO TRACK STATE
AND LOCAL POLICE OFFICERS.
HBO REMOVES GONE WITH THE WIND
FROM ITS OFFERINGS.
LEGO TAKES THE VERY BRAVE MOVE
OF THE CEASING MARKETING LITTLE
PLASTIC POLICE FIGURES.
NONE OF THIS WILL WORK.
GIVING INTO THREATS ALWAYS LEADS
TO MORE THREATS.
THESE WEAK EFFORTS AT PANDERING
ARE ONLY GOING TO ENCOURAGE THE
KIND OF NONSENSE WE ARE SEEING
TONIGHT IN PORTSMOUTH, VIRGINIA,
AND WE WILL GET TO THAT IN A
MOMENT.
MORE CONTROL AND LESS FREEDOM,
THAT’S WHAT’S COMING.
BACK IN JANUARY OF 2019 I TOLD
YOU TO WATCH OUT BECAUSE
NEW YORK CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ WAS NOT
SOMEONE TO BE DISMISSED BUT IN
FACT, SHE WOULD SOON BECOME THE
THOUGHT LEADER OF THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY.
PEOPLE ARE SURPRISED WHEN WE
SAID THAT.
WELL, I DON’T WANT TO PAT MYSELF
ON THE BACK BUT, MY PARTNER IN
MARXISM HAS ALSO BECOME A FOLK
HERO.
>> WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO DO TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT’S ARE DEFENDED?
>> WE NEED TO COMPLETELY
DISMANTLE THE MINNEAPOLIS POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> Laura: IT TAKE LONG FOR
THEIR WISH LIST TO DOMINATE THE
CONVERSATION.
THEY FIND THEMSELVES
>> MY MAJOR BUSINESS DISTRICT IS
JUST SHATTERED.
WHY WOULD WALMART OR CBS -- >>
WHY WOULD WE TELL OUR RESIDENTS?
>> THANK YOU ALDERMEN.
NEXT QUESTION?
>> NO, I WANT AN ANSWER.
>> I THINK YOU ARE 100% [BLEEP].
>> I STILL CAN’T GET OVER THAT.
THEY WERE LITERALLY CALLING AND
BEGGING MAYOR LIGHTFOOT TO SAVE
THEIR BURNED-OUT NEIGHBORHOOD.
LIGHTFOOT BASICALLY TOLD THEM TO
[BLEEP] OFF.
SAME OUTCOME IN ST. LOUIS BY THE
WAY, BEGGING FOR MERCY FROM
TYRANTS LIKE LIGHTFOOT OR
RALPH NORTHAM OR
MAYOR de BLASIO OR GARCETTI,
THE MORE YOU BAG THE MORE THEY
TAKE.
IT DOESN’T WORK.
IF YOU HAVE A 401(K), IF YOU OWN
A HOME OR HEAVEN FORBID
SOMETHING YOU WANT TO OWN A
HOME, IF YOU WANT SAFE STREETS
AND YOU WANT POLICE TO SHOW UP,
GOOD POLICE OF COURSE WHEN YOU
NEED THEM, DO NOT EXPECT
JOE BIDEN IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
HELP YOU.
IF JOE BIDEN WINS IN NOVEMBER OF
THE NT FIVE BLM CROWD IS GOING
TO GO THROUGH HIM LIKE A HOT
KNIFE THROUGH BUTTER.
WHOEVER IS REALLY GOING TO BE
GOVERNING THE COUNTRY WILL KEEP
TRYING TO CUT DEALS WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
UNTIL THE MAIN SYMBOL OF AMERICA
WILL JUST BASICALLY BE A BUNCH
OF NASTY GRAFFITI AND CHARD
BUILDINGS AND THOSE WILL BE OUR
MONUMENTS.
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AND EQUAL
TREATMENT UNDER THE LAW WILL BE
REPLACED WITH A RING OF CULTURAL
TERROR AND RETRIBUTION AGAINST
THE OLD ORDER.
JUST ASK THE LAW-ABIDING
RESIDENTS OF SEATTLE.
THIS IS WHAT THEIR CULTURE OF
REVOLUTION LOOKS LIKE.
[CHANTING]
"BLACK LIVES MATTER."
THESE LIBERALS ARE WHAT THEY ARE
GOING AFTER.
ALL OF US WHO STILL BELIEVE IN
FREE THOUGHT AND FREE DEBATE WHO
ARE AGAINST THIS CAMPAIGN OF
BULLYING AND INTIMIDATION HAVE
TO SUPPORT OUR RETURN TO PEACE,
PROSPERITY AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, YOU MIGHT THINK
HE IS ROUGH AROUND THE EDGES,
BUT HE’S THE ONLY CANDIDATE WHO
WILL STAND UP AGAINST THE
AVERAGE AMERICAN.
WE NEED HIM TO WIN.
BUT THAT’S NOT ENOUGH.
THE DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE TOLERATED
AND INDEED LAMENTED THE SILENCE,
WE NEED TO TEACH THEM A LESSON
TO TAKE BACK THEIR PARTY FROM
THE RADICALS WHO DOMINATE THAT.